-Shawn and I are
about to face off
in a new game we like to call
"Slay It, Don't Spray It."
Now, here's how it works.
We're gonna take turns trying
to sing well-known songs.
We'll have most of the lyrics
in front of us on cue cards.
But when the music stops,
we'll only see a blank,
and it'll be up to us
to finish the line correctly.
If you don't get the lyrics
exactly right,
the microphone in front of you
will spray water.
-Exactly right? There's not even
a little bit of wiggle room?
-No, the judge
is really mad today, too.
He's very upset. Bad day.
But if you can slay it and
sing all the words perfectly,
then your opponent
gets sprayed in the face.
-Oh. I didn't know
that part of the game.
-Oh, yeah.
-That's even better.
-Oh, wait.
I don't like this game at all.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, here we go.
Let's put on our safety glasses,
because safety is sexy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
All right, Shawn,
you are up first.
Go ahead and
hit that button, here.
Let's see what song
you're gonna get.
-Oh.
-That's not easy.
-So I have to rap right now.
♪ I like it like... ♪
-It's clear that
I'm a singer, right? I'm not --
-Uh, Cardi B, Bad Bunny,
J. Balvin.
Okay.
Let's see if you can do it.
"I Like It." All right.
Please don't slay it.
♪♪
-All right.
I'm gonna try it.
♪ Now, I like dollars,
I like diamonds ♪
♪ I like stuntin',
I like shinin' ♪
♪ I like million-dollar deals ♪
♪ Where's my pen?
I'm signin' ♪
♪ I like those Balenciagas,
the ones that look like socks ♪
♪ I like socks and rocks ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh!
"I like socks and rocks."
It's not "socks and rocks."
Can we see that back?
'Cause I really enjoyed that.
That was fun.
I was nervous.
[ Laughs ]
I was nervous, man.
All right, all right, all right.
Here we go.
-You're reading the lyrics,
and then they just go away,
and you're like,
"I don't know..."
-You were great
up to that point.
I go, "Oh, no.
I'm gonna get sprayed."
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
Oh, no.
-Oh, yeah. Here you go.
-Uh, just do the part
where it's...
♪ Whoa, oh-oh ♪
Just do that part.
-...100,000 lyrics.
-Aw, man. Whew. All right.
♪♪
-1, 2, 3...
-♪ Damn, my AP goin' psycho,
lil' mama bad like Michael ♪
♪ Can't really trust nobody
with all this jewelry on ♪
♪ My roof look like a no-show,
got diamonds by the boat load ♪
♪ Come and all my friends,
and they -- ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Tuba plays sad foghorn ]
-I was a wimp about it.
I turned my face.
You went --
You took it straight on.
-It's something --
"the clowns and the bozos."
Something I --
Gosh! I'm sorry.
Post, I didn't get that one.
-Sorry, Cardi.
-Is this game over?
No? Okay. All right.
Let's try -- Your song up next.
Hit the button.
[ Beeping ]
-Okay.
-Come on.
-You know the lyrics to this?
-I think so. No, I don't.
-Okay.
-I know a little bit of it.
Oh, here we go.
-1, 2, 3...
♪♪
-♪ Gold jewelry
shining so bright ♪
♪ Strawberry champagne on ice ♪
♪ Lucky for you,
that's what I like ♪
♪ That's what I like ♪
♪ Lucky for you,
that's what I like ♪
♪ That's what I like ♪
♪ Sex by the fire at night ♪
♪ Silk sheets and...
champagne on whi-- ♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Tuba plays sad foghorn ]
-"Champagne on rice"?
-The worst part about this --
-Dude, that is not the lyric.
-I said, "white."
-No. I don't know, man.
-Now I know it. I know it now.
-You do know the words?
-I think it's "diamonds on
white" or something like...
"Diamonds on white."
-Ah, it's too late!
It's too late now!
You said "champagne on rice."
So that is...
-I don't remember saying "rice."
-All right. Here we go.
I got to wipe this off, 'cause
I can't see the cue cards.
Here we go. All right.
-We suck really bad.
-Did I break that?
[ Beeping ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's cheating.
That is cheating.
Of course, I'm not gonna know --
-I told them to pick this one.
That's -- I kind of know it.
But...
♪ La-la, la-la-la ♪
Oh, no. Okay.
♪♪
♪ I'm on tonight,
you know my hips don't lie ♪
♪ And I'm starting
to feel it's right ♪
♪ Attraction, the tension ♪
♪ Something then
the thing on my body ♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Tuba plays sad foghorn ]
-I thought you had it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I thought you had it.
-This game's rigged.
-This is the first time
you're playing this game?
-Yeah. Yes, of course.
Gosh. What is it?
What is that lyric?
-I don't know.
-♪ Something,
somethin', a body ♪
Don't do that again.
All right. Let's do one more.
But this one here
is gonna be a duet.
This is the final round.
If we slay it, we're safe.
But if either one of us
messes up, we both get sprayed.
-Oh, it's -- Ohh!
-No, I'll be good.
-No, I'm saying "Ohh"
for "I'm sorry."
-Wait. What?! No!
We got to play together.
We can do this, man.
Come on. Wonder Twins.
-All right. Wonder Twins.
-Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right. Here we go.
-Wonder Twins.
[ Beeping ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
What do you mean? Oh, no!
He's too young for Queen!
This is insane!
-No!
-Oh, God.
-Let me take the spray alone
if I mess up alone.
-No, I'll take it.
I'll take it.
You can do this. Come on. Get
in your "Wayne's World" vibe.
-This is my question.
If we bounce off of each other,
do we have to say every word
at the same time perfect?
Can we bounce off each other?
-Yeah, we can bounce.
-All right. Let's do it.
-Judges?
Judges say we can bounce.
-All right.
-I know it.
I think I can do this.
-Let's bounce.
-Yeah.
-One, two, three, four.
♪♪
One, two, three, hey!
-♪ I see a little
silhouetto of a man ♪
♪ Scaramouche, scaramouche ♪
♪ Will you do the fandango? ♪
♪ Thunderbolt and lightning,
very, very frightening ♪
♪ Galileo, Galileo ♪
-♪ Galileo ♪
-♪ Galileo, Figaro ♪
-♪ Magnifico ♪
-♪ I'm just a poor boy,
nobody loves me ♪
♪ He's just a poor boy
from a poor family ♪
♪ Sparing his --
From this monstrosity ♪
[ Buzzer ]
-Gosh!
Sparing his rice?
Champagne on rice?
For his monstrosity?
[ Laughs ]
-That was so much better
than I thought it would be.
-No, it was not bad.
That's my man right there.
Shawn Mendes!
Whoo!